there's a seventh grade
teacher who has just gone viral on Tik
Tok for explaining how his fourth grade
how his seventh grade students are
reading at a fourth grade level so I'm
not really understanding why they not
telling y'all like we all know that the
world is behind like you know globally
like you know because of the pandemic
and stuff but I don't understand why
they not stressing to y'all how bad it
is like I'm not even trying to be funny
but these kids
are I'm going just say this I teach
seventh grade they are still performing
on the fourth grade level
I don't care how you flip it turn it
swing swing it Swindle it they still
performing on a fourth grade level a
nobody talking about how they just keep
moving passing them on they just keep
passing them on passing them on passing
them on passing them on passing them on
passing them on I can put as many zeros
in this gra as I want to they going to
move that child to the eighth grade next
year ain't nobody talking about that why
they not talking about that why they not
telling y'all that Y and why don't y'all
know that y'all kids not performing on
that great level why y'all don't know
this why y'all don't know all really
like this guy I like I know he's he's
speaking in a way that's a bit unusual
you know but he's observing a true
problem and he's saying why why aren't
they letting you know this these kids
are completely failing and and they're
not going to be left
behind
because the liberal governing
structure would rather deny reality and
fail these kids and put us all in a
worse situation then acknowledge that
there's a problem and that and that they
themselves have failed to teach students
and try to fix that problem so that the
kids are actually brought up to the
level at which they should be
reading you're not helping any you're
not doing anybody any favors by denying
reality you're not doing anybody any
favors by pretending that they are
succeeding when they are
failing you you are compounding the
problem you're going to make the problem
worse for everybody you're going to make
the problem worse for all of society
because believe it or not even in our
highly ideological AG age societies
still require some degree of competence
in order to function we live in an age
where we think that as long as you have
the right opinion this is on the left
and even on the right as long as you
just have the right opinion everything's
going to be fine but that's not true the
the the grain mills are not going to
keep on churning just because you have
the right opinion about some LGBT issue
the trains are not going to keep moving
the traffic lights are not going to go
from green to Red the the airplanes are
not going to keep flying in the sky the
the basic functions of society the the
sanitation workers are not going to keep
keep things
flowing just because you have the right
opinion about some obscure ideological
fashion people need to know basic things
the society needs to know how to how to
read at least the people running Society
need to know how to read they know how
to do math they need to know how to do
math they need to know how to I don't
know change a tire really like basic
stuff if if a society can't do that it
doesn't matter how many high futin
opinions it has it's not going to
flourish it's not going to function some
of this is existential we're seeing a
lot of things break down right now we're
seeing the economy begin to break down
we're seeing Supply chains break down
we're seeing food break down we're this
is this was exac ated by Co but it's
been a long-standing trend we're not
we're not functioning at the level that
we need to be
functioning and that problem does not
begin when you elect Joe Biden it's
exacerbated when you elect Joe Biden but
that problem begins when you when you
just keep graduating these people from
the seventh grade to the eth grade when
they don't know how to do the fourth
grade
material that's going to exacerbate
crime problems it's going to exacerbate
poverty problems it's going to
exacerbate problems of government people
aren't going to know how the government
operates it's going they're not going to
know how to vote they're not going to
know when they're being taken advantage
of by
demagogues if the citizenry doesn't
understand basic things how is the
government going to function when we are
supposedly a self-government right now
go to goodranchers.com use promo code
NOS we all have a lot on our schedules
with how much we've got to do every
single day you got to take your kids to
sports you got science fears you're
prepping for the holidays well the good
news is you can take one big thing off
your plate by putting great meat on your
plate with good ranchers you care about
what your family eats so does good
ranchers that is why they've spent years
building relationships with local farms
to Source the best 100% American beef
chicken pork and now wild caught Seafood
the best of the land and sea can be
delivered directly to your door I just I
just adore good ranchers they're
currently offering two years of free
ground beef to anyone who subscribes
which is a $480 value and insane they'll
also lock in your uh price for 2 years
which is in insane especially with high
inflation right now they guarantee you
100% American Meat it is by far the best
in the business it's not even close when
I was a kid stake was a very special
occasion kind of thing now you can have
steak delivered to your door for your
whole family for an incredibly low price
use code nesg goodranchers.com for 25
bucks off and free ground beef for two
years remember to subscribe to any box
to lock in your price on America's best
meat goodranchers.com promo code NES KW
for over $500 in savings subscrib to
good ranchers American Meat delivered
Donald
Trump surprisingly contrary to what so
many people will have you believe has
excellent message discipline when he was
asked will you be the speaker of that so
thank you I'm happy to help but no I'm
not I'm running for president I'm up 50
points so he always hits I'm I'm up I'm
leading I'm the number one guy I've got
the nomination but it's not just that he
then goes further and he says he just
launches into a stump speech he says the
econom is terrible and everything under
Joe Biden's awful and families are
hurting and the borders open and
whatever the parts of his stump speech
are he launches right into it he never
misses an opportunity to hammer home the
four or five points on which his
campaign is built which which
contradicts something we've been told
about Trump which is that he's a
demagogue Donald Trump is not a
demagogue Donald Trump for all of his
sins for all of his flaws for all of his
eccentricities is kind of the opposite
of a Dem OG a demagogue is one who
totally changes his message based on
what group he's speaking to a demagogue
is like uh Peron one Peron down in
Argentina or for a more modern American
example Bill Clinton Bill Clinton could
go into any room and he could charm the
pants off everybody and he could have
everybody believing that he agrees with
them Barack Obama does the same thing
Barack Obama once bragged he said that
in politics he could go into a room and
make everyone in in that room even if
they have different views think that he
was on their side that's not Trump trump
can offend people even who are on his
side but he's going to stick to his
message every one of his speeches is the
same thing we got to stop the
immigration we got to build the wall we
got to have trade tariffs we've got to
make America great again this is a
country in Decline he just hits the same
points no matter who he's talking to he
could be talking to a a crowd at the
Maga Auditorium or he could be talking
to his grandmother is going to stay the
same thing and he's focused and he he's
clearly running as though he's already
clinched the nomination he's running for
the general now could he could he we see
an upset in Iowa
maybe wouldn't count on it Trump is
still leading in Iowa among committed
delegates I think it's something like
two to one over his next rival Dan
santis but maybe maybe the disantis
campaign puts everything into Iowa and
they pull an upset in Iowa they would
have to do the same in New Hampshire
which doesn't look possible because I
think the santis is four or five in New
Hampshire now so maybe I don't know
let's say Nikki Haley pulls an upset in
Hampshire okay and then you get down to
South Carolina who knows maybe Tim Scott
maybe Nikki Haley pull an upset in South
Carolina and then what's going to happen
in Florida probably Trump is going to
win Florida I don't know maybe maybe
disantis wins Florida I don't know then
you go to Nevada almost certainly Trump
is going to win Nevada I
just for for all of these
campaigns I just don't see how this ends
up any different than it did in 2016
there were there were all these moments
when Cruz could have won it or Rubio
could have won it or Kasich probably not
casic but somebody could have won it and
it just it just never materialized and I
don't see that any difference now other
than that Trump is up by even more than
he was back then boy what a ray clip
that was now make sure that you ring the
bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time